o que fazemos quando recebemos um não
algum sonho nosso
todos nós damos maneiras diferentes com
a frustração que é termos negado algo
que acreditamos em algo que sonhamos ao
que projetamos para nós mesmos
a grande questão é como essa frustração
pode determinar as escolhas que a gente
faz a nossa vida e mais com essa
frustração pode determinar o caminho que
a gente escolheu tirar essa história do
joão
joão foi uma criança depois de um
adolescente por fim um adulto
extremamente dedicada tudo que fazia
os dois melhores escolas trilhou essa
parte do seu caminho sem grandes
problemas
passou em todos os anos das escolas sem
recuperação tinha diploma de inglês
francês espanhol e atividades extra
curriculares diversas e um dia a vida
pediu uma resposta mais séria de joão
joão qual é o seu grande sonho nessa
vida
joão decidiu que queria ser médico bom
aluno que era só não teve grandes
problemas
passou no primeiro vestibular e começou
sua realidade todo empolgado com o
caminho estava trilhando em seis anos
ele iria de encontro ao seu grande sonho
e joão estudou joão cresceu joão
progrediu joão se desenvolveu
ele gostava muito de pensar que ele
estava num caminho que elevaria a
realização de um grande sonho
só que joão também tinha um pequeno
sonho joão era um jovem que gostava
muito de ensinar às pessoas
por isso ele determinou que durante o
período do seu curso da sua faculdade
ele teria uma pequena missão um pequeno
sonho
joão queria transformar o conhecimento
das pessoas que estivessem próximas dele
a melhor maneira de fazer isso
formalmente dentro de uma universidade
seria através de um processo de
monitoria uma espécie de programa onde
alunos trocam experiências e
conhecimentos entre si
o grande problema e o primeiro grande
obstáculo a esse sonho de joão é d os
processos seletivos para este tipo de
actividade onde estudava não muito
concorridos e para alcançar esse pequeno
sonho
joão se dedicou o feito que a cartilha
mandava seguiu todos os passos
estudou revisou estudar de novo só que
pela primeira vez na vida de joão ele
não chegou onde queria
apesar de seu esforço incondicional e
dedicação
as coisas não saíram muito com ele
acreditava que sairia e ele recebeu pela
primeira vez na vida um grande não
ensinam transformou profundamente o joão
aquele menino extremamente concentrado e
consciente do caminho que escolheu
trilhar extremamente determinado sobre
as suas escolhas se perdeu se
transformou essa frustração essa perda
desse pequeno sonho fez com que joão
meio que se perdesse fez com que joão
duvidar da sua competência fez com que
joão questionar se colocasse em xeque os
seus sonhos ea partir desse dia tudo
mudou
joão decidiu que seria uma pessoa
diferente
diferente como ele deixaria de ser
aquele jovem determinado consciência das
suas escolhas e se transformaria numa
espécie de super homem tinha que ser
todo tinha que dar conta de tudo o
grande objetivo dessa mudança de joão
era que a obra passar todos os sims
todas as oportunidades que aparecerem na
sua frente
ele queria provar para o mundo que
multava errado quando ele ganhou esse
primeiro não inconscientemente joão
trocou aquela trajetória clara com
escolhas bem definidas por um percurso
um pouco diferente onde ele dizia sim a
todas as oportunidades que apareceram
pra ele
isso mudou tudo a partir desse momento
joão transformou sua rotina agora de
segunda a sábado de sete da manhã às
sete da noite joão tinha tempo para
quase nada
ele fazia muitas atividades algumas
verdades parecidas com ele outras nem
tanto
e aí o tempo passou e o tempo passou o
dia joão começou a refletir
ele tinha muita dúvida sobre como esse
caminho bem delimitado que tinha
estabelecido se transformou e começou a
questionar como as atividades que ele
tinha que ele fazia o levariam para
aquele seu objetivo a realização do seu
grande sonho
ele passava muito tempo fazendo muita
coisa mas o que aquilo realmente tinha a
ver com ele
ele começou a questionar como o seu
caminho sua trajetória linear tranquila
está lina com escolhas bem determinadas
que se confundido no percurso confuso
obscuros em muitas respostas
e quando a gente fala disso a gente pára
pra pensar quantos nós não somos como
joão
quantos de nós diante de alguma
frustração de algo que dá errado de
algum sonho que nos retirar
respondemos com ânsia de referência de
um tanto quanto de frustração e
irritação
a gente quer provar para o mundo que o
mundo tá errado muitas vezes a gente
abrir mão dos nossos ideais das certezas
dos nossos caminhos provar para o mundo
que ele está errado então na verdade
essa história só do joão
nessa história de muitos de nós
inclusive quinta que hoje para contar
essa história
isso acontece com a gente por um motivo
bem simples a gente é treinado para
lidar direito com as nossas frustrações
a gente é ensinado a buscar
incessantemente o sucesso e só ele nos
interessa
tudo aquilo que é diferente não merece
atenção no nosso radar
a grande prova disso é que a grande
maioria de nós enquanto crianças tirou
uma trajetória de relativo sucesso
a gente recebeu muitos ims alguns poucos
nãos
a gente se acostumou com sucesso a gente
aprendeu a lidar com a nossa falha
direito e por que isso
a grande prova é que quantos de nós
recebemos quando pequenos a seguinte
frase em se algum dia você se dedicar e
as coisas não saírem tanto quanto o
esperado
fique tranquilo vai dar tudo certo
quantos de nós a gente foi preparado
para buscar o sim a gente vai preparado
pra potencial sucesso que muitas vezes
vêm com ele mas a gente não foi
preparado para gerenciar os nãos a gente
vai preparado para gerenciar nossas
próprias frustrações ea gente começa a
se questionar será que às vezes as
dúvidas sobre os nossos futuros e os
problemas do nosso presente não podem
ser originados de algo que aconteceu de
errado lá o nosso passado
será que a gente lê dous de maneira
correta com as coisas que deram errado
lá atrás
a partir desse tipo de questionamento a
gente tem que pensar que ter um sonho
negado
foi algo que nos transformou o que nos
tornou mais conscientes do nosso caminho
o que nos fez um ato de rebeldia e de
fúria jogar tudo pro alto e tentar
provar para o mundo que estava errado ao
não negar esse pequeno sonho é a partir
disso que a gente tem de que a vida
assim determina muitos nãos para alguns
índices só que acontece com a gente na
maioria das vezes o nosso cotidiano é
apenas uma demonstração maiúscula de que
esse é o jogo da vida e como é o jogo da
vida a gente tem que aprender com ele
para continuar jogando
eu quero dizer com aprender com ele a
gente tem que aprender a regra do jogo a
gente tem de aprender a lidar com as
nossas frustrações
a gente tem que entender que as nossas
frustrações elas não devem ser uma força
motivadora da gente a gente jogar tudo
pro alto quebrar o nosso status quo e de
repente começar tudo do zero tentando
dizer sim para tudo
as nossas frustrações elas devem servir
como uma espécie de força motivadora no
qual a gente tem um processo de
autoconhecimento e que a gente tenta se
conhecer melhor e mudar quem a gente é
porque não aconteceu acontecer de novo
a partir dessa resposta que deve começar
a moldar o nosso caminho é a partir 10
desse entendimento que a gente tem que
fazer as escolhas da nossa vida porque a
frustração é muito mais do que um
balanço final e sim
apesar de parecer uma grande sessão
aprender a lidar com isso é uma das
regras do jogo da vida
e foi isso que joão percebeu joão com o
tempo começou a pensar
sobre como ele queria lidar com isso ele
começou a entender que é perfeitamente
normal que a gente algumas vezes se
dedica às coisas elas não aconteceram
como a gente espera é perfeitamente
normal que às vezes a gente não atingir
nossos objetivos
então essa não é a história só do joão
nessa história de muitos de nós a grande
mudança que joão teve sorte que
aconteceu na sua vida foi quando começou
a entender isso de maneira muito precoce
ele entendeu que a frustração não era um
monstro porque ele tinha que matar
ele entendeu que a frustração era uma
oportunidade oportunidade de se conhecer
melhor
a frustração era na verdade ao que ele
poderia transformar e poderia
transformar ele também uma pessoa melhor
alguém mais consciente das suas escolhas
mais conscientes do seu caminho
a grande mudança nessa postura de joão
também fez com que essa transformação
deixasse de ser um monstro ser visto
como uma espécie de exemplo de
autoconhecimento
foi isso que determinou a mudança na
trajetória de joão ele entendeu que a
gente tem que refletir sobre o que
aconteceu de errado
e mais ele entendeu o que a gente tem
que refletir que aconteceu de errado
aconteça de novo e isso gerou um
aprendizado maiúsculo para joão a nossa
experiência na mente um carro com os
faróis voltados para a prata
pode ser que essa experiência seja muito
mais de algo motivador de uma mudança do
que alguma coisa que a gente deixa e do
que um sonho que passou todos nossos
olhos
pode ser que a frustração e se
transforma em muito mais do que um sonho
que deixamos de viver
pode ser que ela sirva de motivação a
gente chegar mais longe
pode ser que ela molde o nosso caminho
mas joão o que aconteceu com joão
acontece que ter tomado esse não de
maneira tão precoce é um dos melhores
presentes da vida para o jogo porque
joão entender o que realmente era a
frustração ea entender o que era
frustração ele começou a refletir sobre
o que ele deveria fazer de diferente
a questão é se não se repetisse nunca
mais que ele fosse mais feliz
é lógico isso é muito difícil aprender a
lidar com o que há de errado com a gente
é muito bonito de falar é muito difícil
de fazer mas a grande verdade é que tem
recebido e se não foi realmente um dos
maiores presentes da vida de joão porque
se não colocou joão novamente no trilho
dos seus sonhos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]